the non-uniform case center problem
given by different observers so thanks
for letting me talk so I'm going to talk
about this new problem the non-uniform K
Center problem it's a it's a class as an
example of an heterogeneous or non
infant resource allocation or resource
location problems which this is one
example and they sort of change the
complexity of well known problems and
interesting to understand what kind of
techniques would solve them so this is
the problem that I will talk about so
before I go into the non-uniform key and
central problem so what's the case enter
problem so this is a classic problem so
the input is a metric space and an
integer K and the objective is to find a
subset of these points K in size so that
this thing is minimized so what is this
thing so for every point X in the metric
space I look at the minimum distance to
the point in C so this is d X comma C
and I look at the worst possible points
I max over all points in X this is the
quantity that I want to minimize just
this is the original case centered
problems in this picture maybe case 3 I
want to put this red dot so that this is
the max max farthest point from this to
red dot and this I want to this distance
I want to minimize okay so so another
way of putting this is the following I
am given K balls of radius 1 and I want
to place this ball so I want to find the
Centers of these balls so that with the
minimum dilation alpha these balls cover
the whole metric space okay so that's
the same restating on this problem
okay so why is this problem interesting
well here's a very important application
I have am the city and I have ambulances
three ambulances maybe and I want to
figure out where to put this ambulances
depots for his ambulance s so that every
every house in the city you know as as
close to the ambulances as possible the
ambulance can reach as soon as possible
to the worst guy okay so if you think
I've made up this problem I have but so
have other people so this is one of if I
if I started digging up the first paper
which studied this get center problem
with the paper from seventies and you
know sort of the motivation another
interesting thing I found it this is a
paper by Christopher DS which is not on
TSP okay so what's known about this
problem so this problem as if you think
about bits related to the dominating set
problems in a graph a nominating set is
the set so that every other node has at
least one neighbor in that set and
finding the minimum dominating set is an
np-hard problem and just this fact makes
you shows you that the K Center problem
you cannot get a approximation factor
better than two Y if you have a
dominating set of size K then the opt is
one everyone can connect to the center
at hop one and if it is not K then if
you any K points you open the minimum
distance at least one guy has to travel
is to okay so you cannot hope to get
better than factor to this was not in a
paper by suing them houses before I was
born and there was a very very nice to
approximation algorithm given after I
was born so and I'll tell you what this
two approximation is this is by Dodie
and David and it's a beautiful so here's
the here's the algorithm right so
suppose opt is one I can scale the
metrics so that again is you know the
opt is one which means that there are K
I can put off has like you can put K
ball so that it covers the whole metric
space
these are the octopods I don't know the
algorithm says you know take take any
any point draw a ball of radius - okay a
cover some points then take another
point which is not in the Monod covered
by these points draw a ball of radius
two and go on so maybe you did for case
for here and if I cover everything I'm
done that's two approximation because
everyone is covered by balls of radius 2
and the claim is that you cover everyone
because if there is another point it is
not covered there are K plus 1 points
which pairwise distance at least two and
like pigeonhole principle one one of
these two must be in the same ball but
it didn't same ball they must be within
distance - okay so it's a very very very
nice algorithm which gives an optimal
factor-2 approximation so I just trying
to say that how it's a very simple
problem
very clever dope okay so coming back to
this ambulance example what if my
ambulance has had different rates right
so I had two ambulances of which could
move at 30 miles per hour but one that
could move at 60 miles per hour then the
Depot location problem of where should I
put the ambulances changes because the
faster ambulance can cover a larger
radius in the same amount of time
alright so this is sort of what I mean
by the non-uniform K Center problem
solve this problem I would like to have
non uniformity in my centers and so let
me make the problem concrete
I must say that these slides were made
painstakingly last night so you can see
some good animation here and there okay
here's the problem so I've given in a
metric space X comma B and now instead
of one number K I'm given K 1 R 1 K 2 or
2 up to k HRH okay so these are summing
the rights of the ambulances what's the
objective the objective are to put
centers so there are K 1 centers of
radius r1 k th center the radius R H so
I have to put the center's and again I
want to for every client it looks at the
nearest center it can get 2 divided by
the weight of that Center so it's D X
comma C by RC type C's opened there and
I want to again look at the worst client
the client who gets served the so let me
let me I think this clearer if I put a
be the sort of the ball notation so
again so I can I have n points in the
metric space and now I have balls K 1
balls of radius R 1 K 2 balls 2 of
radius R 2 KH balls of radius R H
instead of like K balls of radius 1 I
have no different classes of balls and I
want to find the Centers of these balls
so some balls are large samples are
small so that this minimum dilation of
these balls
covers the whole metric space that's the
problem there's a problem clear any
questions yeah
good eye I could have just said
Arwen there could have been repetitions
here right as in that's what you mean
like yeah so this will play roles and
how many types of rates I have will play
a role so in the case Center problem I
had only one radius all of one and this
the whole point of the stock is to get
people excited to solve the problem
depending on the complexity or H so you
yeah they're going to be short talks
please ask questions otherwise I'll
finish early and the mall I can take my
time being said that okay so here's the
reason of one reason you might be
excited that this problem actually
generalizes another problem which is the
K centers with outliers problem so which
is what is this problems again in a
metric space I'm given two integers K
and Z and the objective is to you know
so all but maybe Z points I don't need
to cover right so if I what is the again
the objective is the same amount to
minimize the worst clients instant
served okay
so I claim that this is a special case
of be non-uniform K center problem with
two kinds of radius where there is a I
have K cent K balls of radius 1 and I've
Z balls of radius 0 so I just put the Z
balls on the outliers and the other K
balls will expand the same thing okay so
this this problem does you know it
generalizes another problem so let me
generalize two problems I think it makes
a V of study so what's known about this
problem so if you think about it this
algorithm you might say well let me keep
growing these balls till Z people are
left out and that sort of doesn't work
and you have to be a little more clever
and there's a greedy algorithms we have
to grow this balls in a greedy fashion
and this was given by a paper by Moses
cement color inner semen and mount sobre
2001 there was a three approximation so
you lose a factor from the two becomes
three it's a very clever out and
combinatorial okay that was known
for this problem so what do what do we
get what are the results that we have so
when there are only two kinds of radius
all right so there are K one of radius R
1 K 2 of radius R 2 we can get a
constant factor approximation constant
is not that bad it's 1 plus square root
5 and probably came in right now in
particular for the outlier version where
one of the radius is 0 we can get a two
factor approximation that's pretty
simple that's one kind of result and we
have what I call a brittle impossibility
of unique criteria algorithms so if the
number of types of radius is part of
input you cannot hope to get unique
criteria algorithms no no factor
basically okay and I will I will say
what what I mean by brittle here so when
you have an impossibility vemma criteria
result you'd like to see if you can do
anything by criteria
what does biker idea I mean can you open
more centers with this and get a
algorithm and that we can so we can get
an order one order one by criteria
approximation which means that I can
open order ki centers of type I and each
of them will also violate them so balls
of radius order RI I'm not going to talk
about this this is sort of takes more
work but I'm going to show order log
star n order 1
but I think the main sort of surprise
for me was that this problem he's
connected to another problem called the
so called firefighter problem in fact
the firefighter problem on trees and
maybe I'll tell you what remind you of
you of that problem or if you were for
the first time this is a very cool
problem and given a tree and yeah let me
not go into the story but here's the
problem here's the thing that we need to
find we need to select a bunch of nodes
n such that every root leaf path has one
node from n ok and the constraint is
that every layer so the rooted tree can
be thought of as a layer graph every
layer should have at most B notes and
all minimize B that's the firefighter
problem
so the first time you think about who
have not heard of it it seems like this
problem should be easy to solve but what
is quite amazing is that it is np-hard
to decide between B equal to 1 and B
equal to 2 so even even when the trees
has this problem is a NP it's np-hard to
decide whether I can have one per layer
and save all the leaves or two per layer
and save other lives
okay
you can test believe you can touch at
most one leaf say yeah bean leaves yeah
doesn't change the problem on the other
hand if you think about it that this
probably if the tree is of small depth
then you there's a polynomial time
algorithm by a dynamic program okay so
there's a reason I'm telling that so
small depth trees are solvable
so this is the so this is a connection
to any Casey so suppose I have the you
know hard instance of a firefighter and
I want to construct a metric so here's
the metric I basically is the tree
metric where the costs are exponentially
growing so we just have cost C these
have C square all the way proceed to be
it sees the I'm trying to say that there
is no C factor algorithm so that's the
metric and what do I have as the the
radii so I have one ball of radius CH
one ball of radius e to the H minus one
one ball of radius see now you can see
that well sort of convince yourself that
if there was a way to put one node at
each level to to you know make all the
leaves survive you basically put a ball
of that radius in that place in the
metric space and save all the sub tree
leaves so if if the firefighter value is
one in one leave suprises then i can
have a you know like basically every
every client will travel at most two and
when I travel I mean travel divided by
the by the rate on the other hand if you
cannot put one guy at every layer and
save all the leaves then no matter what
you do in this and UK see instance
someone has to travel a sub tree across
straddle a sub tree and will basically
pace see okay so this is sort of
standard so you know you cannot get
better than C factor C by two factor
okay so but note that this is brittle so
why is it Britain first of all the
diameter suppose I want to say there is
no actually if the number of types that
is H and H is a constant then the
hardness just breaks down because the
firefighter problem is easy on it
in fact the NP hardness kicks in only
when the number of frets is like theta n
so so here's an open problem and this is
you know you can I remember giving a
talk once and I gave open problem
Michelle say that he started working on
and didn't listen to the rest of my talk
but the problem is that solve this
problem get unique criteria algorithms
for constant age even three okay so
having said that let me move on to the
algorithmic part so we showed that the
firefighter problem leads to hardness
for this app for any KC problem only
from Cassandra problem
now I would like to say that the
firefighter algorithms lead to
algorithms for this problem okay and the
way that that will go is by LP
relaxation so we're going to write a
natural LP relaxation for the Nanyan
front case enter problem and then we'll
convert it into we get a tree and a
feasible solution to a naturals an LP
let's into the firefighter problem which
has all the properties you need so so
here's the LP so let me write this LP
there for that
so it says it's a standard LP it says
there's a variable x QT which says what
to what extent a ball of radius type T
is opened at the point Q right executing
so variable x QT and what do I want so
I'm going to assume that I can cover
every the whole metric space with no
dilation of a optimal dilation one this
is without loss of generality so if this
is the case then the LP must say the
following so for every point P in X
there must be a ball that covers it that
ball could be of one of this edge types
of radius equal to 1/2 H and indeed if
it is covered by a ball of radius R T
there must be a point Q within distance
R T where X where you have opened a
opened a ball of that radius so let me
write that slightly differently so Q
such that distance of P to Q that moves
RT
beauty and this should be at least one
yeah this is just a normal covering
constraint so that's one constraint and
the second time of constraint says that
well you cannot open too many balls of
the same type so for every type T look
at how many balls you open up that type
that's just the sum that should be at
most solve this LP and now we do the
following I'm going to construct a tree
and a fractional values on those trees
so the leaves of the tree that my points
of the metric space and the fractional
value Y on this is 0 so this is the
picture and my radii is our I am
assuming our r1 bigger than our two up
top with an RH
so at level I I have grown this tree up
to this level I and what happens is
there is going to be one winner who
trickles up so these these points are
going to trickle up one of them will
trickle up as a winner
so for example in this tube among these
two one of them is a winner the winner
goes up here the pink one goes up is a
winner yellow goes up is a winner okay
so when your septic thing up I'll tell
you how who are the winners again just
so this is a node in the tree but it all
loads correspond to certain points in
the metric space just by figuring out
who is there in the leaf and the y-value
and the winners is what so at level I
why you which basically corresponds to a
point P it's the coverage that P gets by
radius radius of type I okay so why you
is I look at all points within distance
RI and how much amount of coverage is by
balls of radius R okay so that's why you
so that's the that's how the y mass is
given on each note yeah good so I should
tell you how this trickling up happens
[Music]
so each level corresponds to one of
these one to H Y and H starts here and H
goes up
so who do I who do i propagate up so so
there's a greedy ruble here and I'm this
is the only probably one non-trivial it
in this algorithm that I cannot just
propagate any one i propagate the guy
who has more social so this these levels
are capturing how much coverage are by
balls of radius I and below and i
propagate the guy i who has the least
coverage from those radius I am below
okay so what do I let me make it
concrete so for any point P this so I
know that if I go if I if I sum from 1
to H this thing is at least 1 and this
is summing up from I to H so this is the
coverage that point P gets from balls of
radius I and a smaller RI RI plus 1 in
this so among these points whoever has
the smallest coverage is the one who
propagates up for example in this
picture maybe these are the coverages
from below so the guy which has the
smallest coverage below the red guy will
be the winner
what's what's that so let me describe
the algorithm so he's going to be the
winner and now this red guy in the
metric space draws a ball of radius 2 RI
minus 1 similar to this idea so draw the
ball of 2 RI minus 1 and whichever
winners of the level I it sees maybe it
sees this yellow guy it that guy becomes
its child
with a bunch of winners I look at the
coverage below this level I look at the
guy with the minimum coverage that guy
you know transcends up draw the ball of
radius 2 RI minus 1 the radius for the
level I minus 1 it sees some probably if
it sees no one it has no neighbors but
say it sees this yellow guy in that ball
of radius 2 RI minus 1 in the metric
space that's his new children and then
the whole tree is finished like so then
I look at the remaining guys in this
level whoever the smallest coverage
value that fellow tree comes up and this
goes on okay so there are two things I
need to show and what one thing I again
need to show so what happens when I do
this balls of radius 2 RI minus 1 what
happens is if I look at the total Y mass
on any level that will be equal to
basically this mass right because
[Music]
any two points so for example the red
guy and the blue guy the total y mas
that I I I put them because they're
balls of radius 2 RI they cannot share
points so these these points which are
within radius RI are disjoint for the
red guy and the blue guy and therefore
if I sum the wise it's as if I'm summing
the X Q eyes and there is no double
counting so the total mass the y mas on
each level is at most ki okay so that's
going to be one thing that's going to be
important and the fact that I am
propagating up in this greedy fashion is
that when I end every root leaf part
will have at least value one y value
want some of Y value one y so for
example in this picture the red guy one
all the way and the red guy has total Y
value one because it was just the x QT
that it faced it so it was a coverage at
level H H minus 1 and so on up to this
root and therefore that guy is one and
then but he but I'm going to claim that
means the yellow guy is one because
whenever the yellow guy gave power to
the red guy its coverage videos only
only larger so all in all this
construction gives this tree and a y
value on the notes such that two things
one every root leaf path has total Y
value one and every layer has total
layer I has total Y value at least see I
that's like sorry at most he I but
that's a fractional firefighter problem
so I'm putting fractional firefighters
fractionally I'm putting these nodes on
on the street so that every root leaf
path is covered and every layer has at
most
what's a non uniform version but that's
fine every layer I has at most K I fired
that was what we wanted to do get from
an LP solution for the non uniform case
center this firefighter and why did you
want to do because for the so maybe this
is the lemma that we get if the
firefighter LP for height eight streets
has integrated a gap Rho H then we can
open Rho hkt balls that would be the
violation
the number of firefighters are opened up
and this is I did not do this but the
total coverage every client can connect
to one of these centers by traveling
this much is the sum of the radius of
which it needs to travel ok so that's a
lemma and then if you do standard tricks
by saying that just you know Club
radiates at powers of two oh ok so
before I do standard tricks what is this
Rho H so it turns out that for fire for
heights to trees this is trivial
actually observation the firefighter LP
has no gap so for when two radii is this
implies a constant constant factor and
in fact when one of them is R 1 is 1 and
R 2 is 0 you get to factor so that's 2
factor for the K Center with outliers
this breaks down at three type of radii
because I think firefighter problem the
indicator gap is not one even one for
three height three trees
definitely not for height for threes but
maybe not frigging height three tree so
it breaks down very soon so this
approach won't work for the problem that
I said and again in general for any tree
the the diga diga is log star n and if
you do the standard tricks of grouping
these ladies and powers of two you get a
log star n 8 approximation this is a
this this log star n result is herb's
very nice little bite challenge sook and
chew toy 2010 I sort of you remember I
promised to order one order one so how
is oh and and this LP integrity gap is
actually tight you cannot it's you
cannot be better than log star n but I
promise in order one order one and this
actually came up because of a fantastic
result by Rico who's in the audience and
a - Willie and Biagio from soda sixteen
or seventeen so a seventeen but it was
found in 2016 as always happens and they
gave an order one approximation for the
firefighter problem and it's not a black
box thing but if you go into their
technique and I'll I know I think Nico
should give a one-hour talk and then I
can follow up on this you can get an
order one order one approximation so you
need to do a little more work to get
okay so so so again I'm going to restate
my open problem is that when H is
constant when H is 3 can you get
constant factors and in general if you
think about as a generalization of K
Center with outliers if you think of as
a nuanced clustering problem I have big
clusters medium clusters small clusters
can you find these solace clustering
problems so we don't know and that's
very curious as in this LP integrality
gap is bad so how do you attack this
problem ok so this is what we saw saw a
non-homogeneous it's a non trivial
generalization open algorithm for
consuming types connection to the
firefighter problem but you know you if
when you look at these resource
allocation problems with different kinds
of resources similar thing happens for
example there was a we again looked at
the capacitated K Center problem so we
have this heterogeneous capacity K
central problem in Ipoh this here again
if you have constantly many capacities
it's open to get unique right so there
are no unit criteria algorithms in
general but you have constantly many
types I don't know if you can get unique
criteria or Durbin approximations and
here there was connection to some
scheduling problems which which are
still open
so with that outliers and to didn't do
you know anything for that so so so
three H equals three but one of them is
zero see I'm actually not 100% sure if H
equal to three is we cannot do because
we I'm not sure integrity gap comes in
already but you know there are experts
here nice perinea they're experts here
who said that they can so but if there
is an integral D gap this technique
won't
work some other techniques might but
yeah - I'm sorry a question I don't know
yeah yeah so here's a problem I do just
look normal
makespan minimization identical machines
so there isn't Peters for that but now I
just say every machine can get it most
fi jobs yeah yeah exactly
maybe login if you allow yeah even for
the one center there's multiple things
that possibly as the governing problem
oh sorry I yeah another obvious problem
caning ask for we did for K Center can
do for K median K means because K median
with outliers there is a constant factor
but it's pretty complicated as far as I
know and like the K center with outliers
we cannot this technique fails and the
point where it fails you can exactly do
the same thing but you know say there's
a greedy rule in trickling up this thing
and in came median there's already
another way of look at clients by their
connection costs and these two though
well yeah they can be different and you
know that's a that's a technical reason
why this doesn't work so yeah it does
not we don't know for median what to do
for median for two types even we don't
know if there are so hardness is all go
through median is hard and even on a
line it's hard so but if you look at
constantly many types in fact two times
we could not make this go through yeah
that's a good point
[Applause]